[MUSIC PLAYING]
Episode eight is a big episode because Uncle George
has to kill Leanne.
And he's struggling with that.
[SOBBING]
For Leanne, at the end of seven, she's broken with this cult,
essentially.
And she's been taught all these things.
Don't wear the fancy clothes.
Don't have close relationships.
Don't listen to music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She finds this record player.
And she starts to connect with this artist.
We're not supposed to listen to music.
They say it's a dark temptation.
But I don't understand that.
It's a beautiful way to show Leanne
and this fictional singer connecting in their pain.
Anything that feels good is dangerous.
She goes to Julian, who's the other kind of damaged
person in the family.
She passes a line with him and goes into territory
she can't return from.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At the end, Leanne, when she finds out
what Uncle George is planning to do,
her temper, which is pretty fierce, comes out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everybody lies to me.